hello everyone welcome to this new video
on reasons to learn devops by simply
learn meet John a software developer who
has been working in the industry for
over five years John has been hearing a
lot about the verbs lately and how it
has been revolutionizing the software
development industry he wonders with the
learning devops would be worth it and
that's when his colleague Brittany helps
him out
hey have you ever considered learning
devops yeah I have heard of devops but I
am not sure why it's such a big deal
I've been hearing a lot about that
lately and it seems like a valuable
skill to have I mean why should I invest
my time and energy into learning it
great question there are several reasons
why learning devops can be beneficial
and first and foremost is increased
collaboration one of the biggest
advantages of devops is increased
collaboration between development and
operations team by learning devops you
will be able to better understand the
needs of the operations team and work
more closely with them to ensure that
the software you develop runs smoothly
in production this collaboration would
lead to a more streamlined and efficient
development process
second is faster time to Market
now devops can help organizations
release software Faster by automating
the software development process and
improving collaboration between teams
devops enables organizations to release
software more frequently and with fewer
errors this faster time to Market can
give organization a competitive
advantage in the industry and third is
improved quality now devops also helps
improve the quality of software by
automation testing and deployment devops
ensures that software is Thoroughly
tested and free of Errors before it is
released this improves the overall
quality of software and reduces the risk
of bugs and glitches in production
so has been around for a while now and
it's here to stay in fact its principles
are rooted in continuous Improvement
Automation and efficiency which are
Timeless Concepts even if the specific
tools and Technologies change the core
principles will remain relevant moreover
the demand for devops professional
continues to grow investing in this
skill set can future proof your career I
hadn't thought about it that way it
makes sense that the principles behind
devops would endure even as technology
works okay you have convinced me where
should I start if I want to learn devops
well you can always start with learning
about Basics like tools and upskill
yourself you need to learn about the
tools and Technologies like puppet and
ansible and continuous integration
deployment with Jenkins and gate that
are used in devops let me tell you about
this amazing course that you can opt for
improving your devops knowledge simply
learn Caltech postgraduate program in
devops is a professional development
option that will Square your skill with
industry standards their cutting-edge
Blended learning combines live online
devop certification classes with
interactive Labs that will give you
hands-on experience devops certification
course will also cover Advanced tools
like puppets solstack and ansible that
helps self governance and automated
management at scale it will also help
you learn about popular tools and use
them in your caption projects that can
actually uplift the weightage of your
resume also it's a self-paced program so
you can explore and learn about devops
anytime you want thanks for the advice I
will definitely look into these
resources it seems like learning devops
will not only improve my skills but also
give me a Competitive Edge in the job
market absolutely I'm glad I could help
learning devops is a worthwhile
investment and I'm sure you'll find it
valuable in your career
luck on your devops joint
journey in conclusion learning devops
can be a game changer for software
developers like John well to motivate
you more and give you a better
perspective here's a success story that
can give you a push to have a look go
live here I started my ID Journey with
Accenture three years ago I joined the
asset Cloud architect there I worked
with AWS and Azure Technologies I was
anyway looking for higher paying job and
devops seem the right career choice so I
decided to go with the postgraduate
program in devops in collaboration with
Caltech ctme force was divided into
modules
and we had assignments
I was really impressed by how many job
interviews I landed after I added a
certification to my portfolio and now I
am earning 40 more than my previous job
didn't only boost my career but also my
confidence well this was all about
reasons to learn devops I hope you found
this video informative do give this
video a thumbs up and share it with your
friends also if you have any questions
please feel free to ask away in the
comment section our team will reach out
to you as soon as possible thank you and
keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here